cette fonction il occupait depuis huit
ans les du front national philippe
chevrier conseiller municipal à
rambouillet et conseiller régional d'île
de france a été démis hier de son poste
de secrétaire départemental du parti
c'est en raison de sa participation à la
manifestation organisée à jean marie le
pen le premier mais il n'est pas
possible d'avoir des des fonctions de
sodexo soit d'encadrement au front
national en participant à ce mouvement
qui étaient hostiles au plan national
une proximité avec jean marie le pen
dont l'élu ne s'est jamais caché depuis
son adhésion au parti
je rencontre comme vous l'avez dit
fortement jean marie le pen
évidemment je suis beaucoup de
réticences et j'ai posé les questions
franches sur l'antisémitisme et la
xénophobie sur un tas de choses chez
alors et ses réponses a été absolument
de l'éclair s'est montré clair et
convaincant
donc du coup et en même temps bon il
répondait à un souci concernant l'euro
et le et le loup erding frontière donc
bah voila j'ai j'ai adhéré tout à fait
normalement et puis progressivement
j'étais responsable de circonscription
du côté de rambouillet
et puis mais après départemental
philippe chevrier n'a pour le moment pas
encore donné de réponse officielle à la
presse concernant son éviction mes
comptes communiqués dans les 48 heures
quand on est impliqué dans un mouvement
politique les partis politiques sur dd
des rouages essentiels de la démocratie
française c'est quelque chose de très
important il faut observer la discipline
de ce parti et les considérations
personnelles d'amitié éventuelle de
fidélité peuvent passer qu'après marie
christine arnautu vice-présidente du
front national et bruno gollnisch était
aussi présent à la manifestation du 1er
mai et ont été priés de quitter leurs
fonctions